I am Japanese and I hated myself.
I hated myself for being different from others.
So, now I'm here hoping to change the world to a place...
...where all minorities can feel embraced.
There was a horrific incident last year in Jerusalem...
...when six people were stabbed in a hate crime attack...
...at a gay pride parade.
We hear shocking news of LGBT people being attacked and killed...
...in hate crimes all around the world.
However, for those of us living in Japan,...
...this extreme violence is hard to understand,...
...almost to the point of being unimaginable.
So, does this make Japan a country that truly embraces diversity?
My answer, sadly, is no.
Japan, I feel, is still a closed and intolerant country.
Let me give you an example.
A boy at one of the top universities in Japan committed suicide...
...after experiencing severe bullying for being gay.
Unfortunately, this is not an unusual case.
Seventy percent of the sexual minorities in Japan have experienced bullying in school...
...with 30% of those consider suicide.
What Japan is facing is unconscious discrimination towards minorities.